foreign
science and medicine and evolution and
the ways that these things interact and
how they are understood by
um by many people in these fields and by
the public generally and this is
prompted by there's an op-ed published
in stat on the 24th of this month so
that's that'll be yesterday
called fixing U.S public health will
require a Health Systems Revolution and
for Physicians
to take a back seat wow that's so the
headline is I'm going to read that with
the right intonation fixing U.S public
health will require a Health Systems
Revolution and for Physicians to take a
back seat
so the same author published a similar
piece in the nation which if you just
want to show my screen here for a moment
this is again same author Eric Reinhardt
this was published a couple days earlier
on February 22nd also this week which is
called want to fix Public Health stop
thinking like a doctor Public Health
requires seeing the world from a
collective perspective but U.S agencies
are still dominated by doctors trained
to work on an individual level
so uh I want to First
share a bit a couple of paragraphs from
this piece that strike me as well let me
just share a couple paragraphs first and
you can again show my screen if you like
Zach this is a PDF but it's exactly
that's it's the nation article
um that came out this week by again Eric
Reinhardt in a section that he calls the
hazards of clinicism
when we treat patients doctors are
appropriately oriented around taking
care of the individual in front of us I
should say that the author is an MD
when we treat patients doctors are
appropriately oriented around taking
care of the individual in front of us we
recognize that we typically cannot
change their life circumstances such as
economic and housing conditions
employers demands student and medical
debt neighborhood violence or social
isolation and so we focus our clinical
attention on helping them live as well
as possible within existing constraints
Public Health by contrast is about
treating populations as with medicine
the goal of Public Health is to enable
individuals to be free of Health
limitations that curtail their ability
to live as they please but Public Health
pursues this by very different means the
task is not to help individuals
accommodate to oppressive social or
labor contexts it is instead to use the
power of government to change conditions
that are constraining people's freedom
the core tools of Public Health then are
not just vaccines or lab tests but also
policies pertaining to corporate
regulation and consumer safety standards
labor protections public jobs and
housing programs investments in
community health workers
decriminalization and decarceration and
civil rights lawsuits
okay
um so you can
hear my screen back here let me just one
sentence in particular there jumped out
at me you know so far
um like this this seems broadly correct
the the arguments here uh he says
uh
the the role of Public Health is instead
to use the power of government to change
conditions that are constraining
people's freedom
yes
I'm surprised to hear that from someone
who is arguing for what amounts to a
curtailing of Greater freedoms that we
had so much during the last three years
that amounted to uh in order to get your
lives back you're going to need to give
us some of what you've got in order to
be healthy in order to be safe in order
to ah than it went to in order to keep
Grandma healthy in order to keep the
children healthy in order to keep
Grandma healthy or Grandma safe and the
children safe then we're going to need
to curtail what it is that you're
allowed to do take some things away
don't worry we'll give them back later
unless we don't and you know this this
has been the the direction for three
years and the argument here would seem
to be seem to be that the problem has
been too much of a focus on the
individual and not enough on the
population and
um but that seems to me to be indicative
having lived on a kind of a different
planet let's let's fix it okay okay
because I know exactly what's being
alleged here and uh my sense is so far
what they've said in principle is at
least not wrong but the problem is the
in principle it's a heat
it's not a thing
it it is a I will get back to defending
why it is a day later because although
it is authored by a he it is speaking
for something else I believe
but the the issue is here one of net
freedom
right it is not one of instantaneously
measured Freedom the argument which was
persuasive to many at the beginning of
the pandemic
was that in order to control the spread
of the virus and therefore free us from
it later we needed to give up freedoms
in the present that turned out to be
horseshit right it's not even obvious
that the people who were handing down
these policies were interested in us
controlling the pandemic they exploited
it for other reasons and that is a
terrifying story but nonetheless there's
nothing wrong with the idea that one
gives up some freedoms now in order to
have greater freedoms later one
surrenders to the TSA and to the
authority of those on an airplane in
order to have the freedom to go to some
far-off place ashwagandha or somewhere
else in order to see something they've
never seen before
um so anyway the point is trading a a
reduction in Freedom now in order for
greater Freedom later is a perfectly
rational argument to make
and certainly it is true that public can
be a perfectly rational argument it is
not inherently a rational argument in
any place but there is nothing
irrational about making such an argument
it is not a non-sequitur yeah and I will
say that Public Health
if it were to function is about this
very thing there is a conflict between
the individual level of health and the
collective level of Health that can
result in a paradoxical if you free the
individual it reduces the freedom of
individuals on a much larger scale this
this is true but um
seems to me that the argument hinged
hinges that that reinhardt's argument
and yes it is a bigger day that he is
speaking for right hinges on the idea
that practitioners of medicine and
science throughout the pandemic
including and he calls out faucian
bolinski actually it's interesting that
we are now arriving there right that he
calls out basically the heads of
organizations that helped make policy
that many people are finally beginning
to recognize was terrible
um you know almost across the board you
know I would say across the board but
many people are coming to realize that
it was at least many more of these
decisions were bad than than many people
believed at the time
he thinks that this is because uh that
these were individual scientists
pursuing individual
um you know things that were good for
individuals and my argument of course
our argument is has been for almost
three years
um that that's not that's not the
problem here that's not what went wrong
the what went wrong in part is that
science actually wasn't being done that
there was you know there were a lot of
the sort of uh markers of science there
I mean there was even fauci declaring
that he was science
and there were credentials and there
were you know there were papers that
looked really sciency and when you went
into them they had lots of numbers in
them and all of this uh but it wasn't
actually a scientific approach to
understanding what was what was going on
and let me just one more little excerpt
here
before we get back to
um how else you wanted to fix these
first two
paragraphs that I read this is actually
from the paragraph just before in that
same Nation op-ed that I just read and
you can show my screen if you want to
zap but you don't have to he writes
physician and public health scholar
Milton Romer once observed that for the
work of Public Health quote most of
medical education is irrelevant
but neither doctors are relevant medical
knowledge nor relative ignorance of
essential Fields labor history social
anthropology political economy
epidemiology environmental Sciences is
the most troubling aspect of physician
control of Public Health
rather it's a lack of epistemic humility
conferring an inability to recognize the
limits and Hazards of clinical reasoning
with which medical training often imbues
them clinical real clinical reasoning is
not only not the population level logic
of Public Health it is frequently
antithetical to it
so this to me
like perfectly encapsulates the problem
with the conversation that we've that we
have been having that we have been
trying to have publicly and that so many
people so many of the Talking Heads both
in and outside of medicine that are
effectively
um you know making or enforcing the
public policy that's being handed down
to us
is making first of all look at the list
of things that he thinks need to be
included labor history social
anthropology political economy
epidemiology environmental Sciences
where is evolution
and I will talk a little bit more maybe
before I get into this but what I want
to talk about ultimately here why this
is coming up is that nowhere in any of
these conversations
is evolution actually showing up and
what what we have been doing for our
entire careers but um you know publicly
for three years almost three years now
is revealing why having an evolutionary
understanding of the world you're in and
how complex that means the complex
systems that you're engaging you know of
and with must be can actually help you
make informed decisions about your life
and the lives of your loved ones and and
and help you help you be
healthier and more productive going
forward so he's attacking uh the
clinical reasoning of wolinski and fauci
and what I would say is we have seen no
evidence of clinical reasoning from them
or from the vast majority of doctors who
have been in lockstep with things like
mandates and definitely avoiding any
kind of effective treatment and you know
things like putting you know patients on
ventilators as we talked about uh last
last week on Dark Horse
this isn't about a failure of clinical
reasoning
um or the this isn't about the limits of
clinical reasoning to solve public
health problems that may also be true
like you know the fields that he
mentions labor history and political
economy are relevant to a question of
how you know how is it if you're a
doctor and a patient comes in and you
can tell that their diet is crap but
they live in a food desert and there's
no way for them to get good food what
can you do for them right like what you
can't exactly tell them you need to
start eating you know steak and avocado
if they have no access to steak and
avocado right so that is a problem and
that is a that is a conflict a tension
between individual Level Health
practitioners and uh and a society where
public health is actually in all of our
interests
but the problem with the covet response
was actually
deeper bigger and more fundamental than
what he is talking about here it was a
complete failure to think logically
rigorously scientifically and in any way
evolutionarily at basically every single
level and time and time again we got
told stay in your lane it's like you
know what if vaccinology and
epidemiology and virology and you know
on and on and on and on and medical
Medical Science and all of these things
are failing because they are so
specialized that they can't tell what is
going on and we are coming in with a
generalist Paradigm that is evolutionary
analysis and it is time and time and
time again able to predict what is going
to happen next well then maybe everyone
in all of these fields
ought to be getting some background in
experience and thinking evolutionarily
and we would all be better off
I hate to disagree with you do you yes
but I've got to take you to task you're
being far too generous
um in other words it's worse than that
yeah
um and I want to resurrect an idea some
may have heard me invoke it before it's
originally a cybernetic idea but it is
so fundamentally important that
um it belongs squarely in the center of
this discussion okay it is posiwit the
purpose of a system is what it does okay
and what this says is it doesn't matter
purpose of system is what it does right
it's an acronym right what it means is I
don't care what that object claims to be
doing I don't even care what the people
who built the object think it does the
purpose of the object is what it does
and the reason that this is so important
is evolutionary which is that sometimes
even a system that is architected well
for a particular purpose if you build
the right characteristics into it will
evolve into something else and nobody
changes the label on it they assume it
does what it always did so my point is
going to be the purpose of our public
health system is apparently to override
doctors and inflict dangerous treatments
on people that are profitable
I don't know why that's the case or how
anybody allowed it to become the case
but it is demonstrably the case it is
the reason that we had a system and this
is the place that I am I know you know
this I'm not telling you anything you
don't know but the reason that I'm going
to push back a little bit
is that I don't think this was a failure
of our system this was the success of an
Undeclared system that overrode the
system we're supposed to have that's
supposed to protect the public health
the
quite possible that's you know that's I
feel like that's a they're all related
conversations
um but the but the the point that I'm
trying to to make here with regard to to
Reinhardt who as far as I know
it you know I I don't know who he is as
far as I know is trying to make an
argument about the you know the
collective versus the individual levels
of analysis and he is making a claim
that science failed us that what what
has been revealed for the last three
years is that science can't get you
there and what we have been saying for
three years is no
you haven't tested that hypothesis yet
because science wasn't done here we need
actual science we need to actually do
science and I want to recover the idea
that this is really a they giving voice
to a perspective through an individual
who has authored this
um wrong-headed piece but I want to
point out when we spoke last week about
the value what is produced by science
being models that are robust enough to
extrapolate from I want to point out
that the um the idea that we are giving
voice to here in a medical context has a
famous quote that people our audience is
very likely to know from a totally
different context from a totally
different source of absolutely
non-medical source and that is Thomas
soul
Thomas Soul says there are no Solutions
only trade-offs okay now what that means
is that why is he saying that he's
saying that because he is in he is
interfacing with a complex system and
the point is you you if you're
interfacing with a complex system you
either get this most fundamental point
or you're going to be you know making
infantile mistakes until you get it
because it's the it's the Baseline if
you've got a functional complex system
then the point is you probably don't
know nearly enough about the
consequences of the intervention you
naively think is going to improve things
yeah which then brings us to this
question about
and really the the title of that piece
right doctors taking a back seat
now here's the thing
Public Health
is the recognition that there are
trade-offs between the individual level
and the scaled up version over a society
that's real
problem is how good are we at solving
those larger scale problems and I find
it essentially diabolical
that they would go after what just
happened to us as a demonstration that
really we need to double down on public
health because what they did is they
silenced the doctors right they silenced
the doctors and they did something in
lieu of Public Health right it was
Pharma corruption that spoke as if it
was trying to solve a public health
problem
that caused so much harm and what I
believe that article is whether the
author knows it or not and the author
may well not know it the author may just
simply be following a signal that
something needs to be given voice but
that voice is Pharma having captured the
system now trying not to be ushered out
the door on the basis of all the harm
that was done saying well that wasn't
real Public Health right what we really
need to do is get rid of those people
who screwed up the public health
response and do some real Public Health
it's interesting that actually in at
least one of those two articles by the
same author published within a couple
days of each other in Staten and the
nation
he has
um primer corruption and uh and and
perverse incentives maybe not named
exactly that way but he he calls out
Pharma uh which you know is exactly it's
part of why I focused on the nation uh
article you know we
we were long time uh subscribers to the
nation and uh criticism of the role that
Pharma had in public health was one of
the things that I had come to expect
from them and that we have seen from
nowhere on the left you know for the
last three years and finally we're
beginning to get these little
intimations and you know it's going to
come with some whitewashing and some
disappearing of history and some
pretending and some lying and that's you
know that's some stuff that we would
we're going to try to make sure it
doesn't happen
um by by those who would like to pretend
that they got it right all along uh but
okay if if the nation is coming back to
its roots in which it understands uh
that those things that have power will
try to protect their power and therefore
you can't take literally all the things
that they tell you about what they're
doing and why they're doing it then
maybe we can get back to some kind of
conversation about what has actually
happened well I've got to tell you I'm
struggling not to be cynical about this
but I take pieces like that one that at
this moment would double down on
so-called Public Health A system that
has just failed in this way I take them
as part of what we have called the
middle ground scramble and the idea is
nobody at this moment is going to be
taken seriously in any conversation if
they don't scold Pharma right so the
scolding of Pharma is obligate in a
piece like this in order for Pharma to
keep its captured entity and to continue
to sideline doctors who at the end of
the day have to face the patients and
the fact is medicine has a
multi-thousand year history
right we have some successes in public
health and we have some spectacular
failures covid is a spectacular failure
and so the idea of sidelining doctors
after you've just shut doctors up in an
effort to advance the public health
agenda which turned out to be a Pharma
agenda which did all of this harm is
absolutely insane and the you know the
excuse is basically a well real
communism hasn't ever been tried kind of
excuse right we now we have to start
Public Health right after we've paid
this huge Global price and the answer is
no can we at least go back to doctors
who swear an oath not to harm their
patients
[Music]
thank you